[musique]
l'alliance ici à Varsovie de vous quatre
corriger si
faux et c'est ainsi que nous voulions
à l'échelle Dans un an et demi en Ukraine
Nous avons déjà atteint le niveau auquel nous sommes
je voulais déjà créer un deuxième salon à Kiev
grands salons
les villes avaient beaucoup de projets avant
Mettons en œuvre
c'est comme ça qu'on traduit l'orteil comme ça
Ils ont retiré leur doigt et l'ont abaissé jusqu'en bas et
tu marches sur la nuque
la femme trapèze c'est aussi les hommes Et si on
parlons de l'Ukraine, c'est là que j'ai commencé
nous sommes venus en Pologne, personne n'a rien fait
recherché
était très
difficile mais
alors nous avons compris
ce qu'il faut développer pour ne pas
descendez
esprit
[musique]
par exemple, il y a l'éperlan, et c'est tellement baltique
il y a une odeur
Avant notre arrivée, il n'y avait pas de Polonais du tout
je savais ce que sont les rapans, comment les manger, etc.
pas une seule institution n’en avait, c’est pourquoi nous les avons
même certains Polonais viennent maintenant
spécialement pour goûter le rapany
Une telle exclusivité peut dire que vous y allez
à la ville en termes de personnes et de personnes et en général
il y a une telle atmosphère d'aide, ça aussi
c'est vrai, mais nous voulions dire autre chose
[musique]
sur